hey Brian I heard we're demoing bigquery
GIS today what exactly will we be
looking at Lauren you're absolutely
right so today I will be using public
data from the US Census and New York
City Taxi and Limousine Commission to
help us analyze data in different ways
so that users can make more informed
decisions for example we can look at
population hotspots to see where it
might make sense to play stars sounds
very cool and can you talk about the
feature updates made to bigquery to
allow for these new GIS features yeah
absolutely
so the bigquery GIS team has partnered
with the Google Earth engine team to
integrate geospatial data types and
functions into bigquery a lightweight
visualization tool called bigquery geo
va's has also been created for users who
want to quickly plot and style their
geospatial query results on a map for
analysis let's take a look
so I'm a retailer looking to open up a
new store within New York City
specifically I'm looking at this
particular neighborhood around the point
that's shown here if I want to gauge how
successful my stores going to be there's
certain questions that I want to ask
around that point things such as are
there a lot of people who happen to live
around there and is there a lot of taxi
and foot traffic around that point now
whether the standard dimensional
modeling these are questions that are
not necessarily easy to answer however
this is where geospatial analysis is
perfectly suited the first query I'm
going to load up is a simple one this
one is quite simply asking the data set
how many people live within 1000 meters
of that point that we were showing
earlier now when I run this query you're
going to see that according to the US
Census is stating that there's a hundred
and thirteen thousand seven hundred
thirty four people who live around that
point but what makes it so easy is this
particular section within the where
clause there's two things I want to
point out there the first one is this
particular data type here with bigquery
a geospatial information services we
introduced new geography data types
which makes things such as polygons and
points on the map easy to represent
within a query and there are a number of
different functions such as the esti
distance within function we're using
here which makes it very easy to
represent those kind of questions so
instead of trying to finagle a lot of
different joins in a lot of different
ways to query this information we can
now simply just ask it within this
particular geo point how many people
live within a thousand meters of it so
let's take this use case a little bit
further before we were analyzing one
specific store and we were trying to do
a simple query but what if we want to
look at more stores what I have set up
here are five different stores within
the city of New York and they're going
to be represented by coordinates each
one of these I want to link up with both
the census data but I also want to merge
it with the New York City Taxi CAD data
now this is a public data set that is
hosted on Google's bigquery in
partnership with the New York City Taxi
and Limousine Commission and part of
this information also provides for
certain years longitude and latitude
coordinate information for where taxis
are dropped off and so now what I can do
is merge
altogether and not only get population
information but I can also figure out
how many people are being dropped off
within a hundred meters of each of my
stores the idea being if I have people
who are going to be frequenting that
area or being dropped off constantly
maybe they can see my store make an
impulse buy or drop in on the way
they're on to where they're originally
going so if I run this query now I have
points on a map which I can place for
each of my five stores the population
counts within a thousand meters of it
and I can also have a hundred meter
radius count of the taxes that are
dropped off there so if I map this out
and I tell it that these are the points
I want here are my five different stores
I can now add visual cues to indicate
how many people are going to live around
that so let's put some data ranges on it
and so now I have circles of different
sizes around my points which are telling
me how many people live around it and
maybe I want to change the color of each
of these different circles to tell me
using the tax account how many people
are being dropped off in a year around
each of these points so let's give these
different colors going from blue to the
lowest all the way up to red as the most
and interestingly what this is telling
me is that the area with the lowest
population around one of my stores
happens to have the highest volume of
taxi drop-offs within a 100 100 meter
radius and this is information I can
quickly determine using visual analysis
and geospatial analysis to make better
business decisions and hopefully make
future decisions much more efficiently
on where to place other stores so there
you have it folks
Brian was easily able to use geospatial
data types in bigquery GIS to query
information about population at an exact
longitude and latitude locations yep and
I was also able to plot multiple points
on a map in the bigquery govt
tool and later din population and New
York City taxicab data that can now be
used to influence business decisions for
retail store owners if you have a cool
project you're working on let us know
the link for that's in the description
and also don't forget to like the video
leave a comment and subscribe to the
channel thanks for watching
[Music]